-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you had a great weekend.
Let's get to the news.
According to a new report,
President Biden is ready
to help lobby moderate Democrats
to support reforming
the filibuster
and told Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer,
"Tell me when you need me
to start making phone calls."
Said Schumer,
"You haven't even started
making calls?!"
During a speech on Thursday
outlining his new plan
to fight the coronavirus,
President Biden
scolded travelers
who refuse to wear masks
on airplanes.
Great. Now do shoes.
During a September 11th
memorial dinner on Saturday,
Rudy Giuliani imitated
Britain's Queen Elizabeth
by marrying his cousin.
[ Laughter ]
Supreme Court Justice
Amy Coney Barrett
appeared yesterday at an event
with Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
and said she was worried
that the public sees the court
as a partisan institution,
which is kind of like performing
at the VMAs with Taylor Swift
and worrying that people will
see you as a musician.
The MTV Music Awards --
Video Music Awards were held
last night, and Madonna made
a surprise appearance
to open the show.
The audience was so shocked,
they all got out their phones
and looked her up on Wikipedia.
I know. They're young.
I know.
The fast food chain Burger King
last week unveiled
its so-called Keep It Real Meal,
which partners with
several celebrities,
but uses their real names
instead of stage names.
Though I'm not sure how well
the Robert Allen Zimmerman
burger will sell.
[ Laughter ]
An investigation concluded
last week
that a recent MTA subway outage
that shut down 83 trains
was caused by someone
accidentally flipping
a power switch.
Said one man,
"So that's what it does!"
And finally,
Facebook has collaborated
with the eyewear brand Ray-Ban
to release new sunglasses
that can take pictures, make
phone calls, and play music.
On the downside,
you're currently
sitting on them.
And that was the monologue.